hi I'm Jess today I'm going to be asking
to tattoo artists to see if they can
draw my dream tattoo let's go hey what's
up Mitaka I'm a tattoo artist from Los
Angeles I specialize in new traditional
Japanese I'm Denise
I also tattoo and I don't have a
specific style I just had to do whatever
anybody wants at any given moment I see
what's up there's a little bit of
backstory about this tattoo
my best friend took my appointment to
get it so now he's been walking around
with a version of these kind of
components and I haven't come up with
how I want to incorporate my love for
our relationship my love for California
and kind of just my own aesthetic
initially I saw kind of a cross section
of a palm so that's the tree I just
aesthetically was really drawn to it
mm-hmm
the second I saw it I was like that's my
next tattoo okay but I would love to
kind of take the image that exists of
this poem and incorporate then also like
a love for California which to me is
like a Joshua Tree moon a mountain like
mountains or an image of the ocean
something nature this wasn't a hard one
because um when people look at it I
think great thing about that too when
you look at the image you can tell right
away what that is yeah I mean that's
great
I think this gonna have like people
would have a little bit a tough time
seeing what this is right away you know
so you might have to explain what they
are that's okay I mean to me for me the
way that I like tattoos for me are kind
of like reminders I'm totally open to
like whatever I mean like a subject
matter it's gonna be really difficult
and not necessary difficult but just
like really weird to try to incorporate
into like other like regions do you know
what I mean yeah California begin we're
just gonna do what she wants I'm good
just think about whatever California
elements will fit within a diameter and
make sure that it's legible from a
distance we'll see what we can do
[Music]
a lot of times what people want is it
necessarily always possible is it fun to
play with organic shapes like this a lot
more room for error you don't have to
worry about everything being perfect
mm-hmm I hope just likes it
No
[Music]
like the succulence I'm trying to like
oh yeah seconds that's why damn it
Carter is like a palm tree so I'm trying
to make that happen a little bit as you
drill you come up with all this new idea
why you can't even you know okay this is
what I want to do it now you know I mean
it's hard I think yours is way more
legible it obviously doesn't even need
to be shrunk you totally copied me dude
oh yeah they both did a great
I love these saucy blocks up here oh my
gosh I'm really happy that like both
have kind of like have the circle that's
there and like the initial shape but
like added a bit to it I don't know it's
kind of like exactly how I did dream of
of it but actually drawn this is my
dream tattoo okay
so I like the I like this circle
incorporation of like the two flowers
and like kind of like the wild flowers
of California but I like I love that
there's either a moon or Sun whatever
kind of did I pictured it as like the
Sun setting but I kind of like the
inside of this better but I like the
incorporation of the outside better
I think I'm gonna go with this one and
only because of the succulence this was
such an awesome experience because like
I've been kind of sitting on this for
such a long time to like have people who
are really really talented just kind of
map out is like super super cool so
thank you guys so much do I get to keep
these you know I'm good sit or do you
want